Нашою задачею було перепрофілювання
індустріальної інституції на інституцію культурну,
тому що Довженко-центр був заснований
за лекалом Держфільмофонду.
Це поняття радянське — фільмофонд.
Він планувався як сейф, як місце,
де фільми тільки зберігаються.
Ця концепція передбачає контроль
над матеріалом, контроль над контентом:
ви тільки зберігаєте і обмежуєте доступ.
Я це називаю «зберігати від», а не «зберігати для».
Тобто він зберігав «від».
І коли ми починали реформування,
ми хотіли зробити архів доступним.
Кожний робочий день у фільмофонді
починається з включення бактерицидних ламп
та з запису температури і вологи повітря.
Заходьте, будь ласка.
Я працюю з плівкою 50 років.
Тому для мене плівка — це все,
а «цифра» — це так ніби трошки чуже,
але я його не виключаю.
Задача фільмофонду:
зберегти те, що є на будь-яких носіях,
на яких нам воно надійшло.
От один фільм під номером 258.
Це один фільм, починаючи з 258, —
оце починається одна складова фільму.
Фонд сформувався в основному з того,
що залишилось на кінокопіювальній фабриці,
а потім уже було розпорядження студіям:
Довженко, Одеській студії.
І вихідні матеріали, що ще залишались
на цих студіях, передали нам.
Після обробки, після всього ми ще змогли
отримати позитивні копії нормальної якості.
Ось, власне, наша проявна зала,
де відбувається обробка плівки.
Ця машина — перша,
на якій проявляється негативна плівка.
Після того, як цей негатив змонтований,
з ним намагаються робити якомога
менше будь-яких маніпуляцій.
Оскільки це вихідний матеріал:
якщо з ним щось трапиться, то це — біда.
З нього роблять так званий дубль-негатив.
У подальшому з цим дубль-негативом
уже працюють копіювальники.
Фонограмна машина використовується
для проявки оптичної фонограми.
І позитивна машина.
Власне, після того, як позитивна копія
роздрукована на копіювальному апараті,
ця копія йде на проявку вже на позитивній машині.
У подальшому ми отримуємо позитивну копію,
яку ми дивимось у кінотеатрі.
Останній фільм, який друкувався
для кінотеатру, був «Кіборги».
Світова федерація кіноархівів,
членом якої ми є з 2006 року,
досі вважає єдиним доведеним верифікованим
способом довічного зберігання фільмів плівку.
І ми стали дуже активно працювати
над реставрацією і над архівним кіно,
створенням, власне, продукту.
А потім ми зрозуміли,
що ми можемо і контекст задавати.
От коли ми говоримо про виставку ВУФКУ,
це вже загальнокультурний контекст
задається цією виставкою,
це вже не просто породження смислів,
ми створюємо цілий історичний наратив.
Від нас залежить, як люди будуть сприймати
той чи інший історичний період
у кіно і в мистецтві.
Від нас залежить. Тому що ніхто в Україні
цим більше не займається.
Увесь кіномасив,
який був знятий у роки ВУФКУ, був маловідомий,
і про ВУФКУ до цієї виставки
говорили дуже мало.
В фізичному сенсі ми можемо говорити
про втрату близько 54% фільмів.
Загалом ігрових фільмів було знято
понад сто двадцять
за вісім неповних років
роботи цієї організації.
Цікаво, що Всеукраїнське фотокіноуправління
на початку включало не лише професіоналів,
точніше, їх було дуже мало.
Не було людей, які спеціально вчилися
кінематографії або акторській майстерності.
І більшість із цих навичок кінематографісти
опановували на ходу,
але в кіно вони прийшли з літератури,
з театральної сцени.
Це були просто дуже вправні інженери
і винахідники.
Довженко входить у [список]
100 найкращих режисерів світу,
і його стрічка «Земля» є фільмом,
рекомендованим до вивчення
в провідних кінематографічних
вишах світу або факультетах.
ВУФКУ завершило своє існування в 1930 році,
воно було розформоване,
і плівки з фільмами,
знятими в 20-х роках, були передані до Москви.
І тепер для нас — велика і складна задача:
як ці фільми повернути до України,
тому що права на них
належать все ж таки нам.
Якщо в цьому умовному кінозалі
немає глядачів зовсім,
то зображення на екрані
починає битися і стробити,
воно стає або кольоровим,
але його важко розпізнати.
Коли в цю зону потрапляє бодай одна людина,
зображення стабілізується,
і ми можемо спокійно переглядати кіно.
Якщо немає глядача,
якщо про кіно не знають,
якщо воно невідоме — його немає.
Але щойно з'являється хоча б один
зацікавлений персонаж —
кіно починає працювати.
Ми називаємо зараз Довженко-центр
культурним хабом або кластером,
що означає, що він вийшов за межі
власних попередніх масштабів,
Я не думаю, що ви чули про існування
Довженко-центру до 2012, 2013 року. Так?
А він існував на той момент уже 20 років.
Колишня кінокопіювальна фабрика
була просто переіменована,
але залишалася, по суті, фабрикою.
Це інституція, якої не було на карті міста.
І [потрібно було] призвичаїти людей до того,
що тут щодня щось відбувається
і ви можете завжди тут знайти собі розвагу.
Розумну розвагу.
Тепер це, справді, таке осердя низки
культурних ініціатив, здебільшого низових.
Хотіли одразу після революції, коли був
такий вибух креативної енергії в Україні,
заохотити різні низові ініціативи
в громадському секторі для того,
щоб вони інституціалізувалися,
щоб вони досягали сталості.
Ми потрапили в унікальні обставини:
все таки ми всі були наснажені революцією.
Ніхто не прийде і не змінить.
Ніхто, крім нас, цього не зробить.
І в цьому сенсі ми просто усвідомили,
що це таке призначення.
Моя індивідуальна інтенція була
в тому, що це моя війна.
Я не пішов в армію, не пішов служити.
Я розумію, що моя задача...
Я більш корисний, можливо, буду тут.
І це була моя війна,
тому що для того, щоб створити це,
треба було весь час воювати.
У кіно прийшов раз, і його покинути неможливо.
Мені так здається.
Я в 69-му році прийшла сюди контролером.
Були зали для перегляду, вони в нас
так і збереглися з тих часів, і два екрани,
тобто людина сиділа,
вона контролювала зразу два фільми.
Як моя бабуся говорила,
так вона взагалі не розуміла, вона каже:
«Оце ви дивитесь кіно, і вам платять за це гроші?»
Ми тут дивилися — це вісім годин перед екраном отак от,
і ще ми ходили в кінотеатр.
Ви уявляєте? Цього було мало!
Для мене кожен фільм —
це таке дзеркало, відображення мене.
Тобто через фільм ми можемо аналізувати,
і, мабуть, пізнавати себе.
І розкриватися емоційно.
Але для цього до фільму має бути доступ.
У нас є відділ «Медіатека».
Завданням «Медіатеки» буде зробити
доступними матеріали, які у нас зберігаються.
Ми маємо свій кінолекторій,
де уже можна буде
переглядати кінопрограми.
У нас є дитячий простір, де ми вже проводимо
мистецькі заняття з дітьми,
про те, як дивитися кіно
і як читати його символічну мову.
Це дуже важливо — просто усвідомлювати,
що, крім тебе, ніхто цього не зробить.
Тому доводилось вивчати все.
Я, будучи гуманітарієм, вивчив інженерну
систему нашої будівлі, каналізаційну.
Ми повністю все змінили,
всю інженерну інфраструктуру.
Я був вихований у обставинах,
що робота — це достойно. Це почесно.
Немає поганої роботи.
І в тому унікальність нашої команди,
що це люди, які не боялися роботи.
Людина має перевинаходити себе щоразу.
Щоразу ставити нові питання
і давати на них відповідь.
Так смисли творяться.
Бо хтось вірить, що їх можна знайти.
А скоріш за все їх немає,
їх треба винайти, а не знайти.